[Music]
hi everybody dennis prager here and this
is the ultimate issues out of the third
hour every Tuesday is devoted to some
great subject of life even if you have a
map you only know where you are the
purpose of the ultimate issues hour is
to help you know where to go and that
unfortunately is not thought nearly as
much as where we are by I could I
attempted to say back by popular demand
and I think that would be accurate
actually is a professor of astrophysics
at UC University of California San Diego
Bryan Keating his book losing the Nobel
Prize a story of cosmology ambition and
the perils of Sciences highest honor is
now out in paperback he also presents a
very popular Prague review video what's
a greater leap of faith God or their
multiverse so the whole issue of
scientists science God and the related
subjects professor Keating welcome back
to the Dennis Prager show that's a
pleasure to be back with you Dennis how
are you I am very well thank you
so I was discussing an issue in the last
hour in my life what's a good arena
actually the enter I you by any chance
and I don't expect you to be familiar
with God and the astronomer is a book by
Robert Jastrow yes I am planning an
update God and the cosmologists to that
book really is that right well in part I
mean I think it's impossible to not
think about the question of God's
existence or lack thereof and discuss
cosmology you know astronomy is mostly
concerned with you know properties of
stars and perhaps exoplanets and really
fascinating things I hope we can touch
upon today but but cosmology is really
even though the store
of what happened you know perhaps before
there was a history of the universe you
know the ultimate mapmakers in the
universe our cosmologists and that gives
us a certain sense of you know maybe
perhaps hubris but it should in some
sense give us a some humility and I hope
we can discuss why that is so cosmology
is the study of as you know you're very
acquainted with it hair and makeup and
net no it's not it's the study of the
universe the cosmos but it shares that
same prefix cosmos with cosmetology and
that's because that prefix means beauty
and it means space and the universe
presents a face to us that we can reveal
and to some that might reveal the
presence of God so the Jastrow book
offered and he I knew him very well as
by sheer coincidence and I really adored
him he was a very special man anyway he
who was the the the head of the Goddard
Space Center at NASA a very prominent
astronomer of his time so he wrote about
he was shocked to find that how many
astronomers were upset by the news that
there was probably a big bang because
they had all or not all at all but many
of them had really banked
psychologically on the proposition that
there was no beginning that the universe
always was because the beginning
suggests of course a creator where is no
beginning suggests no creator so he said
Wow they didn't really they weren't
neutral scientists they had a bias so my
question to you is do you agree with
that thesis and B is it still true well
those are those are two really good
questions so I'll answer the second one
first and the first one not at all
no I will enjoy about the questions the
yeah usually you impose a one-question
policy on your on your caller in this
case the you know the question of
whether it's true is perhaps the most
interesting question I claim in all of
science so my colleagues would disagree
because it is so intimately
connected to whether or not the universe
had a beginning is intimately connected
to this prospect of the existence or
lack thereof of the multiverse and the
multiverse you know kind of hypothesis
if you will that is sort of a modern-day
incarnation if you will of the previous
generations in the 50s and 60s the
original opponents to the Big Bang
Theory were devout atheist as you say in
particular Fred Hoyle who coined the
term Big Bang apparently as a pejorative
euphemism for a certain type of act that
I won't say in the radio it's it's more
appropriate for the male-female hour
but but I'd invent this this pejorative
was launched because he was a devout
atheist and he actually claimed at one
point that scientist believed in the Big
Bang because they are overwhelmed by
Genesis 1:1 and nowadays you know I
don't think you quote this particular
character and the rational Bible but but
that's laughable right no scientists we
think of scientists today as brightly so
as I say in my pregger you video you
know 70% or more of the National Academy
of Sciences do not affirm or actively
say they're atheist so nowadays that's
completely you know it would be a
laughable opinion to hold in the case of
whether or not the universe had a
singular beginning that question is
extremely hotly debated and in fact
there's evidence that some of the
greatest you know proponents of the
original theory what's known as
inflation that predicted the multiverse
are now coming back to try to kill off
that theory and they're meeting
incredibly fierce resistance not the
least of which comes from Nobel Prize
winners who are you know held up you
know rightfully in some cases not so
much in others perhaps but as having a
halo effect that really bestows upon the
more could credulity in their opposition
to the theories that are presented that
conflict with the multiverse so it's
extremely hotly contested question and
it couldn't be more relevant to today's
science as I discussed in my book right
so that that again raises the question
and I'm not looking for a certain answer
I'm just curious is I'll put it even
more direct
then is science affected by
non-scientific biases
that's that already good at that no you
you've got to be joking yeah of course
scientists scientists do themselves a
disservice when they purport you know
perpetuate this mythology that were
somehow you know walking Wikipedia's
that just have tremendous amounts of
knowledge but you know I always point
out you know Wikipedia has a lot of
knowledge but it has zero wisdom and the
fact that scientists are sometimes the
least aware of these blind spots and
this goes back to ancient times - as I
always talk about my hero Galileo in the
book he was notorious for straying after
what his eyes and his heart wanted to
show namely in his case a correct theory
which is the Copernican model that the
Sun is the center of our solar system
which overthrew thousands of years of
orthodoxy going back to Aristotle but
this question of whether or not we are
the center of the earth that was deeply
ingrained upon him as being wrong you
know prima facie on it you know
absolutely incorrect so everything he
did was seen from that perspective and
he even went to such great lengths as to
you know have an incorrect explanation
for how such prosaic effects on earth
such as the tides that we see at the
oceans or how the Milky Way appears the
galaxies our galaxy and that was biased
by his desire called confirmation bias
to appeal to what he wanted to be true
so absolutely and it still holds true
the court I gave you from Fred Hoyle and
it helps true in the modern incarnation
of the multiverse and it's a concomitant
fallacy logically with something else
that maybe we'll get into called
authority bias which is we tend to look
up to and associate an almost
impenetrable halo around scientists when
we scientists are mere humans and I
think that that's an important thing for
listeners to keep in mind scientists are
humans and we have the same prejudices
biases and proclivities as any other
human being and to say we don't does a
disservice to science because it
prevents people from going into our
field that have the capability to be
scientists you know people say I'm not
as smart as that scientist so I'm not
going to I never make mistakes but
scientists don't so I think it's
important to this
people of that notion I raised the the
well it's very important your answer and
I raised that issue and you don't even
have to comment on this I just won't
explain to you in case you didn't hear
it and and to those who might not have
heard I raised it in conjunction with
the issue of of global warming and that
there's no doubt in my mind in this
regard that the pressure on any
climatologist any any scientists
involved with the climate the pressure
to sustain the notion that we are and on
an irreversible journey toward
extinction is tremendous because to say
otherwise is is to risk reputation and
livelihood that's very unfortunate and I
always say the thing I love about
cosmology is that there's no Republican
constellation there's no Democratic
comments out there and it's mostly a
political but you're right my colleagues
do complain about this you know
off-the-record to me quite frequently
yeah tell me when we come back I'm very
curious
the Dennis Prager show the book that I
had him on originally for is now out in
paperback titled losing the Nobel Prizes
story of cosmology ambition and the
perils of Sciences highest honor
professor of astrophysics at UC San
Diego Bryan Keating and you're saying
about your colleagues I think he was
saying were I had asked you about the if
you agreed that the pressure on a
climatologist to advocate a certain line
is is tremendous both financial and in
terms of reputation and you were then
commenting on some of your colleagues so
if you remember what you were about to
say go ahead yeah I mean I should say
that you know probably a hundred years
ago it might have been the reverse where
someone who was an agnostic or a devout
atheist as I say you know might have had
trouble convincing funding agencies to
fund their
research into non you know Big Bang non
God non creation narratives and and to
some extent that parallels some of the
struggles that my cosmologists
colleagues have I'll just say this
because you know I often get asked to
review scientific proposals most of
which are in my field of astronomy and
but sometimes it's there outside the
fields in general or you know kind of
science wide and I have had the
experience where science work scientists
working in you know let's just say
globally speaking the climate change
research area have had trouble getting
funding and they put that in their in
their funding request that I'm reviewing
so and these are to study you know
anomalies or asymmetries or you know
counter counter to the prevailing
orthodoxy which you know I know you
agree with that the the planet seems to
be warming and but the question of why
it's asymmetric why are there are these
anomalies that can't be explained under
the you know standard climatological
model and and they they get relatively
little attention and this was brought
into very stark relief you know recently
by two events that really captivate in
my mind one with the was this this
climate scientist Michael Mann is a very
famous climate scientist at Penn State
University and he you know he was called
out online for you know faking
credentials related to winning the Nobel
Prize and I thought that was so strange
that someone would you know would do
that and you know for I haven't really
investigated matter two'd in too much
detail but that they would they would
put this down you know as which was not
the case he never did win the Nobel
Prize I looked it up and and this was
just startling to me that someone would
do that and it showed to me kind of this
dangerous a lure that we put in in
certain scientists and and of course the
ultimate blessing that a scientist can
bestow is to win the Nobel Prize so I
agree it is it is conventional and in
most fields that would be the end of
someone's career you know to do
something like that if those allegations
are true now you know again Irish
reporting what I've seen and so
you know it was it was it is certainly
hard for my friends now as I said before
the thing I like most about cosmology
and astronomy is that it is
intrinsically apolitical it doesn't mean
that it's not you know this ultimate
issue relevancy to it because I think
there is no greater relevancy then what
you know what preceded our current
universe was it nothing was it a
creation event what was the creation of
that like was there a creator was there
a designer and these are you know
fascinating questions that currently are
not political
I shudder to think if some day they
became political that would be certainly
the end of you know well it was it was
Jeff Castro's theory was that it it
could be because so many astronomers
were upset that there might be a
beginning to the universe because that
would yes someone who made a beginning
yeah I mean his actual quote is that you
know he he likens the discovery of this
all pervasive radiation called the
cosmic microwave background radiation
that I study this is discovered in 1965
in of all places New Jersey just kiddin
I'm uh I'm a New Yorker so I can make
jokes about New Jersey but but anyway
they discovered it serendipitously and
they found the inescapable conclusion
was that the universe originated from as
the TV show said a very hot dense state
and the question of whether or not that
implies there was a singularity a
creation event a time Jastrow said that
you know the scientists tried to reach
the pinnacle of this mountain and when
they got there they saw a band of
theologians reject loves ah I yeah I
don't like it I actually don't like it
because it suggests they somehow had
some scientific notion where they were
accepting it on faith and that's that's
fine if you're accepting the religious
you know origination of it but my pet
peeve is you know for about non
scientists is that they delegate and
relegate scientific truths merely to
scientist they outsource the thinking
that is required to be a critical
ultimate issues thinker purely to
scientist and why should we have all the
fun and it really would be like me
saying well I'm not only do I not like
music I don't like to you know read or I
don't like to write because I'm just not
good at it
if you want to know the mind of God I
said this on the bench Shapiro show a
couple weeks ago if you want to you know
see into the mind of God there might be
perhaps if God exists there might be no
better window than to learn about the
creation of the universe itself that may
reveal let me tell you why let me tell
you though the reason that I liked that
quote about there was a ban of
theologian sitting on the top
what was I I don't fully accept your
belief that the belief that God that
there was a God who created the world is
belief I don't believe that God created
the world reason suggests it to me uh-uh
that's why my book is called the
rational Bible my vehicle to to God is
reason not faith I I'm not terribly
interested in faith uh if I had to bet
my house on the prospect of everything
came about on its own versus that it was
started by something beyond it I would
bet the second not because I am a man of
faith but because I'm a man of reason
right so there's actually a famous quote
from really essentially the pioneer the
father of the multiverse theory and he
essentially said that he has so much
space literally he said this he has
faith in the multiverse because it
provides a way for the universe to come
into existence and so from his
perspective God is irrational and faith
in the multiverse is is rational and
furthermore he wouldn't just bet his
house like you he would say you're a
[ __ ] he says he would bet his life that
the multiverse is correct this is Andrei
Linde the Herald professor of physics
it's really worth
that is awesome all right ha ha that's
amazing all right one a Prager 776 Bryan
Keating professor of astrophysics at UC
San Diego his book now in paperback is
up at Dennis Prager comm the Dennis
Prager show
bye everybody dennis prager here
ultimate issues our third hour every
tuesday god the multiverse the universe
reason faith professor of astrophysics
UC San Diego Bryan Keating and his a
book losing the Nobel Prize is up at
Dennis Prager comet is now out in
paperback and what is their what is so
we're talking about the last thing you
said was that this believer that there's
an infinite number of universes would
bet his life on it because did he
actually say that or you just countering
my betting my house oh no Lord Martin
Rees and Robert Kirchner and and other
cosmologists were assembled about ten
years ago at a conference and they were
asked to rate their their scale and the
scale of belief system how much they had
caught fate they had in the existence of
the multiverse so Martin Rees said I
have so much faith I'd bet my dog's life
on it
Andrei Linde said he would bet his life
on it and he this pioneering physicist
that came up with the modern
interpretation of how we viewed the
existence of the multiverse and then
Steven Weinberg Nobel laureate who had
come up with some earlier calculations
on the multiverse he said I had so much
confidence I bet
Martin Reese's dogs life and Andre
Linda's life that's very funny
he's funny I'm glad I had to repeat it I
did Kenneth's quotes and and I have
fondness I've read the book I ask great
fondness for gesture but you should know
about an incredibly intellectual honest
man by the name of George Lemaitre he is
actually the father of our modern theory
of the Big Bang he didn't call it the
Big Bang as I said a famous atheist Fred
Hoyle did but George Lemaitre was a
Belgian Catholic priest and an
astronomer and a cosmologists
who proved not only that the universe
could be expanding he proved that
Einstein was was crucially wrong and
Iceland hated him for a long time and
then came to see that he was right well
this Belgian
Catholic priests well on the occasion of
the anniversary of his predicting this
this the you know origin of the universe
the Pope Pope Pius said this is clear
evidence for the Genesis narrative and
Lemaitre had the intellectual honesty to
say it is not scientific evidence of
that and what what is so amazing about
that again he's a priest and he was the
man of devout faith and he was also a
scientist I think that's sort of the
anti Jastrow innocence and that both
opinions I agree it would be it would be
so to speak the anti gesture Bowl I
don't understand why the big bang does
not suggest between the Big Bang and a
multiverse clearly the Big Bang more
suggests a God or a creator than the
other
I mean it's that's that's yeah stands to
reason but you know Dennis you could ask
this question all the time you know God
is infinite you know who made God hahaha
you know people think they're very
clever and they ask that question you
know it's a Dawkins favorite favorite
question in every book that he writes
but in the case of the Big Bang when we
say the Big Bang we actually don't know
what happened after after about three
minutes after the seeming origin of the
elements in the universe's I talked
about in my book we know a great deal
about the physics of the you know what
will happen next Tuesday but we know
about the detailed physical properties
what gravity energy etc in the early
universe but we know almost nothing
about the creation event itself Dennis
have you ever thought just for a moment
if time had a beginning how does time
pass how does time move from moment one
to moment two when it has an origin for
example what happened a minute before
the Big Bang is that always like that oh
yeah I mean I got it occupies mostly
your shower time right no I get it but
that was a very cute line it means you
really do listen but there is no that
that question isn't apparently it's not
legitimate if time was invented if time
was begun yeah if I wasn't an Shi ated
you're right it but however there's a
great deal of work it's kind of like the
op on the
cooling side if you will her I'm a you
know denier side as that hateful word is
sometimes use you know when people talk
about alternatives to the Big Bang there
are very respectable scientists some of
them the biggest names in science today
Paul Steinhardt the Einstein professor
at Princeton University Roger Penrose
who's one of the most famous physicists
in history they have models where the
our Big Bang is just one of an infinite
cycle of Big Bang's now there's no real
I'd hold it there hold it there hold it
there our infinite cycle of Big Bang's
remember where we were I got a root I
got it come back to earth for a moment
and professor Bryan Keating is my guest
for the ultimate issues our he has
written a book the Nobel Prize losing
the Nobel Prize and it is up at Dennis
Prager comm professor of astrophysics at
UC San Diego so we're talking about the
the multiverse which is an infinite
number of universes but now you were
offering now there's a sort of variation
on the Big Bang that it may not be in
contradiction to the multiverse because
there might have been an infinite number
of Big Bang's is that what you were
saying right Yeah right before the break
by the way you were right before the
break you did an ad for a relief factor
and I just want you to know as you know
I nominated winners for the Nobel Prize
and I did nominate relief factor for the
Nobel Prize in medicine so if they don't
get it you'll know it's some anti Prager
bias but getting back to the getting
back to the the question of this
infinite miss and you should know that
mathematicians and physicists speak
about different kinds of infinity so for
example you could count the numbers the
natural numbers 1 2 3 etc to get up to
infinity but you may know there's also
an infinite number of numbers between 1
and 2 they have decimal places 1.1 1.1 1
etcetera you could go on forever doing
that well just as mathematicians have
different kinds of infinities so
do astronomers and physicists we have
different ways of thinking about
infinity that may differ from the way a
layperson might think about it so in the
multi-verse you can have multiple types
of multi versus multi Multi versus if
you will indulge me where there could be
in fact an infinite number of universes
that are completely inaccessible to us
that exist so far outside the horizon of
time the time in which light signals
traveling the fastest possible speed
could ever reach my telescopes there
might be a universe a year a light year
beyond that in which case we wouldn't
find out for another year that's the
conventional multiverse that I talk
about in my Prager University video
however there could be multiple
universes in time as well
cycling from Big Bang to Big Crunch an
infinite number of times or it could
have just occurred once and in some
cases you might have noticed that you
know there is a there is a notion where
things like energy are conserved in our
in our physical world if you if you
bring a swing back and your kid is on
the swing you're giving it a type of
energy called potential energy the
energy possibility to do motion and then
when it's swinging it has no potential
energy but it has all kinetic energy
energy of motion but so you can't
destroy energy can destroy matter but
you can't destroy energy so if the
universe began at a specific moment then
one moment before that moment that was
there was no energy and then it popped
into existence of a moment later that
would seem to violate this conservation
of energy and so people like you know
these theorists that talk about the
universes from nothing they have to go
to great machinations to really come up
with a solution to that problem but
those scientists like Roger Penrose and
Paul Steinhardt and others who posit an
infinite cycle of universes provide the
construction material for our current
universe from a preceding universe that
collapsed and crunched perhaps not even
into a singularity which is this notion
where time and space have infinitesimal
extents and those are very hard things
to contemplate but it's exactly what
what I described in the book how we can
comprehend what it means to be a
multiverse in space what it means to be
a multiverse in time and perhaps most
cunningly of all you
do any of these have observational
evidence it doesn't seem that the
multi-verse as I talked about in my
video has a way to prove it wrong to
falsify it which is typically considered
the hallmark of good science yes exactly
so so how do they get around that so for
the universe's that cycle through time
there are predictions and I should say
this is very much in an immature state
compared to how much effort in time that
people put into the multiverse Andy and
the multiverse in the in the spatial
sense that I talked about in my video
but there could be signatures there
could be patterns that we see in the
microwaves that I detect with my
telescopes along with my colleagues or
it could be some pattern of black holes
that are distributed in a special way or
other exotic things called primordial
magnetic fields and we have design tests
this is what my thrust of my research is
to do it's not to prove something is
right that's a misconception about
science I don't go around trying to
prove stuff I go around trying to
disprove stuff and if a theory makes so
flexible a prediction that no
combination of measurements that I do or
my colleagues you can ever falsify it I
don't consider that worth my time or
scientifically a meritocratic pursuit
right so okay so it comes back to the
issue is a multiverse theory or multi
Big Bang Theory disprovable yes so there
is a possibility to disprove the mutton
the number of the infinite number of Big
Bang's in time you could disprove that
if you detect the type of signature that
my telescope bicep that's the subject of
losing the Nobel Prize my book that we
were trying to detect but again there's
that word trying we when we set out in
science to try to confirm something you
are oftentimes misled by evidence that
biases you in the favor of your original
conjecture and we scientists fell into
that trap and we made a premature we
made an announcement that we later had
to retract and I speculate in the book
how the Nobel Prize influences decisions
like that for scientists but in this
case we can disprove the notion of an
infinite sequence of bangs in time but
we can't prove
move it or nor can we prove that the
multiverse in space exists except in
their very contrived circumstance all
right so so then then then it seems
scientifically untenable tell me why my
conclusion is wrong Bryan Keating
professor astrophysics booked up Dennis
Prager com
talk about the preview videos my guest
has made one what's a greater leap of
faith God or the multiverse professor of
astrophysics at UC San Diego Bryan
Keating his book losing the Nobel Prize
a story of cosmology ambition and the
perils of Sciences highest honor is now
out in paperback and it is up at Dennis
Prager comm you know our our minds can't
can't really grasp what happened before
the beginning we can't grasp what it
means for there not to be time and we
can't grasp infinity is that is that
fair to say yeah those are all true and
we do a better job of it than even a
computer so it's pretty hopeless in the
in the long run to contemplate infinity
but we do our best right but then in in
light of what I just said it let us say
that the evidence pointed to an infinite
number of universes nobody including
those who advocated it would understand
what they just said I'm not saying that
that invalidates it I'm just saying it's
sort of a it's it's to argue for
something that no one is capable of
understanding is it strange isn't it
yeah what's happened is that scientists
took a theory that has a lot of evidence
for it although it's still
circumstantial as I point out in my book
we're really trying to find hard
evidence for it
that's called inflation and from the
circumstantial evidence they sort
circumstantial evidence squared which is
that you know they say the inevitable
logical conclusion of inflation being
correct is that there's a multiverse so
it's like you know it's sort of
circumstantial evidence to the second
power are you in the majority of your
colleagues in your thinking in is it
50/50 are you in a minority I think you
know I because I have this approach
where I believe I take a scientific
approach to religion and that's the
conversation for another another time
but but I do believe that I am you know
have things in common that I do attempt
the testings as best I can
scientifically but I do allow for the
possibility that that God could exist
and I think look if there is a
multiverse Dennis you seem to always
think that the multiverse limits God's
power but why would you say that why
would you say that and to me it would
strengthen God's power again if God
exists I believe we can have reason and
you know and I think you know that's a
subject that's a subject for our next
conversation Bryan Keating his book is
up at dennis prager calm
[Music]